see this islands pretty cool right  playing night-school studios oxen-free  is like watching the cast of The  Breakfast Club act out poltergeist five  teenagers muddled after your favorite  80s movie stereotypes visit a tourist  trap island and accidentally unleash a  paranormal force via radio waves led by  Alex who's dialogue and actions you  control they must unmask  the entities and exorcise them it's a  tale of coping with loss broken  relationships and the inflexibility  with which teenagers deal with sudden  change all layered under an alarming  paranormal encounter I left oxen free  feeling Hollow and strained emotionally  spent yet excited to play again and  uncover more of the mystery different  conversation outcomes and story endings  give oxen-free great replayability  and it's worth going back multiple times  to unearth all of the games Schilling  wore it's a big little game about the  all-too-human inability to let go of  what hurts us